mieux faire connaître du grand public
les applications qu'ils étaient faits au
tissu des manufactures de jouy en josas
c'est toute l'ambition de cette nouvelle
exposition près acquisition aux
collections du musée une cinquantaine de
pièces ont été sélectionnées
on n'a jamais abordé d'aussi près le
thème du motif voilà le motif le dessin
était un thème très cher à oberkampf il
a toujours fait travailler de très
grands dessinateurs
il était très soucieux de la qualité des
dessins qui s'entête ses manies fait de
sa manufacture et ça n'a jamais été
abordée sous cet angle là il s'agit
essentiellement de costumes du xviiie et
du 19e siècle des corps provenant des
indes fleurs motifs géométriques
chaque thématique est ponctuée d'une
création contemporaine pour montrer
comment ces motifs ont été réinterprétés
l'exposition se termine par un podium
dédié à la haute couture
là vous avez une pièce de castelbajac
alors là c'est vraiment il a utilisé un
motif de la toile de jouy qui est un
motif qui est qu'on retrouve dans nos
dans nos archives et il a totalement
modernisé
en faisant des allusions au rock ac dc
j'ai soif de futurs enfin c'est
totalement ses traits à la fois très
humoristique et est tout à fait dans nos
codes
en parallèle de cette rétrospective des
conférences des visites guidées et des
ateliers sont proposés au public
jusqu'en février 2020
[Musique]